[موسيقى]
يحصل احيانا في بعض السنين ان الخط
المناخي يتزحزح عن المعتاد بمعنى ان فصل
الصيفي او الشتاء يتقدم او يتاخر او يتمطط
بعض شيء وهذا امر طبيعي ومعتاد ويحصل على
سنوات متقاربه كما يحصل الان ففصل الشتاء
انتهى ولا ونحن الان نعيش في اول فصل
الصيف لكن اثار موسم الشتاء تنتابنا بين
ان واخر خاصه على المناطق الشماليه فبعض
السنين يرتفع حمو المحيط وتنخفض درجات
الحراره على الاقطاب فيؤثر هذا على تقدم
وتاخر الفصول والمواسم وعلى اي حال فان
فصل الصيف لهذه السنه سيطول على غير عادته
بمعنى انه يبي يدخل علينا موسم الوسم
والصيف ما زال شاد علينا حلمت ان زمان
صيفي منصرم واله حققت الايام رؤياك رايت
احلام اهل الحب كلهم لما مثلت امامي عند
شباكك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفصل الصيف يبدا مع كنه ثريا وينتهي بموسم
مرخيات كانت ثريا اربعين يوما مربحانيه
القيظ اربعين يوما زدحه القيض 26 يوما
وجمره القيظ 26 يوما وبعدها يدخل علينا
موسم مرخيات كذا الصيف عن جرد السبايا ولا
بقى من الغيظ الا مرخيات
القرائد
[موسيقى]